that's why i'm always a
bit humble because i always say
don't fly so high my little friend
you know don't freak out here
now because the day when you
need them all again is coming and we all
shouldn't be so presumptuous to
believe  that we can do it on our own,
but we are all dependent
on people who will always stay
by our side to catch us at the right moment
and if it gets difficult
we will still say no matter we will pull
through together than the thing with values that didn'
really work back then
at least in public in the
published perception above all
the zdf remained very clear on my side and
that that is that is that is big 500
episodes o m r podcast honestly
not all here on youtube but
i would say thank you very much to
everyone who has one episode  have heard
or who have even heard much
more success that makes my job possible
i love my job  and especially
on days when i get great honor
like in the 500 in a row when namely the
most relevant most important
question not relation the markus lanz came
here to visit the little industry
questioner philipp
westermeyer that i then in the 55
do why have  was able to ask my question
about his life his career
does he do push-ups a day like
filming so well deserved with tv shows like that
and yes what else you ask markus lanz
all that let's talk to
markus lanz welcome
markus lanz i'm glad he's with markus
ferber to the joint projects and
the pot coffers
if you don't know a little bit everyone
who now i know a little
bit maybe not so small you
come from extremely small circumstances
in tyrol and then still went in such
a media direction as i
if you think yes then you want to
earn money first goes into business
but n  not so i don't have to
rule that out but
at the beginning it wasn't one of
the ambitions the media wanted to work out
or what was going on
i actually always wanted to be a
music producer that that was
actually the thing and that's why
i thought when i'm in radio I'll be there
i've been close radio
vhr then exactly later but first yours in south
tyrol yes yes that's already
italian territory exactly and
then it worked somehow i always
felt like radio above all that's why
i like podcasts so much that's why
see it now  in contrast to you
here also with with with headphones because i
really like it it reminds me of this old radio feeling the
podcast is terribly modern of course
but for me it's just radio in
digital but the feeling that the music
comes from these circumstances i  mine
that is really worth it is
very depressing yes exactly so history
is also well known i have my father  he
lost early on and then my
mother fought a lot to somehow get us
through it and we all
fought a lot but my siblings
and we somehow managed it quite well i
think but then you
grow up very quickly
that's what happened and then it was
kind of like that  always clear okay now
earn money that's why i
always find it so difficult when a message
comes to me telling me money is not that
important in life and money is not
everything and someone says something i
can say it relatively bindingly so without
money it's also difficult
but all the more so i find
impressed that you then responded to his
artistic
music radio we yes it isn't
that immediately smells of money no exactly
no it went of course that by the
way is a totally interesting point
actually due when you
think about it i am deeply
convinced that we all have
talents and abilities and i
'm sweating it  ger talked about it
said you know i
sometimes sit in the taxi and then i think
probably the guy who is sitting at the front
at the wheel is the much better
actor than me
that was very funny because i
said see that's definitely the case but
but i understand  the point yes and till
has also done a huge thing and
just very focused pulled it through
that I also admire that about him and
against all resistance was yes but also
who was not just hugged and
welcomed but the
breast of the right work and
it's actually like that i think we
all have abilities that we
sometimes don't even know about and
then a security thought comes up,
especially with young people i experience
that i'm always horrified if i
'm allowed to say it like that, for example when i go to
higher universities  graduates who then
tell me pay attention if i study it now
i will probably have a 65 percent afterwards  ability to earn 100,000 euros in the first
year that
kills me then i always think that
's that's that's not life
after all we can't seriously start
wanting to measure everything and
calculate everything that's grotesque but of
course that's the zeitgeist  which means
that we then
try to calculate it ourselves and that is
incredibly dangerous because it is
very tempting when someone
says what even if you study it and
earn 85 percent with a
probability of 8,100 trillion in the
first semester  of
course it's difficult to decide against it
or maybe to
decide for what your heart really
tells you because then the statistics don't say
what you earn with a 35
percent probability of
10,000 euros a month and with a 99
percent probability of 100 euros you'll have it
afterwards  let the money be made but
I have just after deeply
convinced we mu  ssen do what we
really mean but you do the same
so what do you have you deserve an incredible
amount
finally 70 x billion
no I admire what you are doing
there with the festival and so on
what you have set up here that
is great  but that's not money-
driven first of all, but first of
all you can feel it with you every
second, first of all, it's about
doing something that you really want, of course,
but I don't think I
have any rich parents
either, but I didn't have this one  pressure that I have now read out
from these people like
philipp big misunderstanding the pressure
there was in a certain way because you would of
course, so to speak, because the daily necessities of
life etc. you
would think that is clear and the question I
only had old ones my first car was
a  fiat ritmo was so
eaten up by rust that if you looked at the
gas pedal you could just
watch the asphalt with years driving the
pas  take a look at sstrassenconti or
next google but not through
the pane but simply through the
floor and you have to get the opponent from the
cart falls apart program was was was
earning money was important but
probably similar to yours
i think we have a
parallel we had there  a great freedom
we always feel a bit sorry for these
people who then think like this in this
dynastic thought because you
come so close to the
big family of entrepreneurs you have to be precise and then you have to
sell yours in the office although
luca doesn’t want to sell castro either
become or no idea what do
you understand and they always have this pressure
from the assona family there is real
power and also always the danger if you
don't do that then your
credit card is gone my friend yes and that
's just difficult and that's why I found
mine  situation getting better and better i
didn't have a credit card you know when you
all welcome and that noise
Have you ever been standing at an ATM that drew
your card
a long time ago you heard it but
have you ever experienced it? I saw it maybe I was
n't paying attention but
that's not so bad yes yes yes
I trusted myself next this noise
yes you shoot the country was in
this cash machine and
waits for him to say enter the pin
and then you suddenly hear and
then the card is gone where nothing happens
anymore
simply up to the stop in the dispo is of
course not good all the more astonished but
it  is than make yourself free you know that
we are not saying well i would like
that you now in this day and age when you
have now only reached a very high
level nevertheless
interpret this freedom in such a way
apparently probably ask later
that you also consciously ask
we don't give up money maybe because one sees
you could do that i know advertise a
lot partnerships a secret
stands m  it's now a fashion
brand certainly with euromobil brands
with banks i'm quite
sure you have to look good for that so if i
could i could
sign a lot of contracts for you but you didn't know you were
doing that while he was also doing
other things under public law
thomas gottschalk had your flight altitude many
others if that at kerner previous
times didn't do that
well i know of course in the end
it's about a certain distance that
you always have to try to keep and
assuming the best example you would
now advertise for volkswagen  i
think volkswagen is a great
company more than it is a huge
automobile group and now you
suddenly have these risks this scandal
so you are the face of the brand what
do you do vivi how can you
speak critically about it impartially
and vice versa of course also great i
mean  just with herbert diess
the vw boss has you  legendary
interview that i heard recently
that is also shown at universities there
was a moment that
i will never forget i was running in the morning
thinking about how we could
approach this legally very tricky little word
fraud and i always have it that
way  considers that i thought i
have to seduce you a little i have to do it in
such a way that he actually can't
help but say yes to the
question of whether that was actually fraud
knowing that it was legal
and i was in charge of this question and he
says yes it was clear  that cheating and i
think he said that to himself and then
short pause and then i say to him
willful
cheating and then his face froze and there was a pause
that felt to me like three
minutes i think it was five
seconds of total silence  and i did
n't say anything and he just didn't say
anything anymore and then realized that was exactly right
and after that lawyers were at the start is
today that's what i think ric did  still
needed because yes i think i think it
was about the question is
really very interesting and you also notice
the pressure these people are under
i didn’t want to get him into
trouble but in
fact someone like that has to think immediately okay
what the consequences are  did that raise
doubts that was then
requested by the investigators in the usa who
wanted to see it then they were
exactly there and if you then suddenly realize
okay then the
public prosecutor’s office will be
difficult that’s why they have to be so
incredibly careful and on the other hand
we demand  always go to the front
big business people explain to you
tell me what she's up to and so
on explain your vision for
the world of tomorrow and herbert diess
whom i really appreciate because
he's the power but always
have one foot on the abyss  if you are in charge of
such a global corporation then that has
huge consequences when in doubt it
is one too  reason why when you look back there are
relatively few business council or
especially dax or mdax people are hard to
get actually so
i’ve often liked to know about it totally i’m a
total business world that’s why
i’m always offended you have the people yes
what come to you they yes yes i’ll come
maybe that's
the word that means you say somehow
if you now have a christian blissful
or a flower from porsche or something like that
christians just said something totally
interesting the other day i also know that the head of the
deutsche bank had banged,
exactly he said first the country then  the
company
that's crazy that's a complete
paradigm shift that you didn't think of your
generation of deutsche bank spokeswoman
before him in life
what i told you what was that but
that was said somewhere in an interview
or was addressed at a congress or
employee  yes don't
come I have to say I
don't think we tried it at all
but should we give a good hint
thank you and are you also in an
economic situation that you now,
so to speak, would I find it very
interesting have a good feeling for
will be right now ask what
is a zalando worth right now as a company
on the stock exchange you would have felt
it  not at zalando now actually
not i never look so closely
at the capitalization so what is the market capitalization right
now,
especially since everything is always very
volatile or dynamic exactly but
i have an idea of it going like this again and i
have  the other day i
always like dealing with
people like warren buffett and such
skins and he
said the other day it was about stock market
strategy said something great
he said i always do it i
buy something i really like at
a price that doesn't really like yeah
then I lay it down
and then I just wait 20 years and
then the interviewer said if that's the case
easy is why do that
not everything and then he says something is really
interesting he said yes because
people want
to get rich quick but you can only get rich slowly
that was totally heard now no one wants
to get rich slowly while everyone wants to get
rich really quick  that
you would be here too it worked but
tell me if you know that i think
that totally the center point he is this
belgium because she is doing it again
the thing it's always just about money
it's really just about the fast one so to speak
profit then it's
not about it, it's about looking at
what is it that you enjoy, what do you really believe in
and then you invest
what I ask myself about the subject of economics
in economic policy not always
frustrated that they now realize
it's him  a
lot of people will be for podcast
too everything is okay but i think related to 80
million germans if i
somehow  a founder of
zalando or her fresh or the companies
or even speaking it’s always only
60 70 80 thousand listeners yes that
should also be the manager magazin something
neutral the magazine is already something but
you
were also obviously happy to read the management
but it  there aren't enough people so i
think that's a lot more
people should be invited to max bauer and
quotas for business even if he should be for business
then that might just
not work i would
n't
say that's yes i had to
console you a bit  I think so if you
say 60 70,000 but which ones 60 70,000
those are top people who serve to make the
best film the best I
know I mean that's a very
special target group and maybe they are
interesting multipliers
etc. it's always the question of how to  also
gets but what was really to say
that the most impact
preliminary talk so that's just told by cellphones
that on  yes travels with his hand yes and
yes not exactly herbert
diess he just explains what phase
is and you can see i mean i
remember that was smiled at by
many from the car industry too who
said um now he does everything on electric
with it  get rid of your funny this scandal
we continue today shows
how visionary that is and if you but
the worrying thing about it is something
else again when you talk to people like that
then tell you what is the
competitive advantage of tesla for
example and then also tell you the
following  at toyota they tell
you we can do a model s or
whatever, we disassemble it down to the
last screw and we can do everything
and we understand everything and we can do a
lot of it better, yes,
until we get to the processor  and then the end of the
day
comes the heart of the whole story, so to speak,
there comes the software
and then you suddenly notice that tesla is
actually  I'm not a car company at all, it
's actually a software company
with an attached car workshop, that
's actually in truth and then
someone like Herbert Diess tells you when
asked how far ahead they told us
five years, six years and then you get a sense
of how they start then  at vw the
best people in the field of software and so
on to pull everyone together to
somehow catch up and then you meet
me next time asked and we are
now the distance to des la and says there
feeling that was what you thought it was and
that  is the journey of this disruptive at the
moment that is in there right now and that
i don't think is bothering us
but i would say that this is
the conversation that has traveled the furthest so to speak
and are of the opinion that it has had the greatest
impact it has reached the most people
or or  what really was the conversation in
your life that the public led
that developed the most
impact the effects lived on  tfaltet
oh yeah obama was just like that once in a
lifetime just that was like that that
was that was a highlight that makes
you happy and what was nice
was the chamber towards us it was
n't that people weren't invited to
to come to research and probably also the
task is the costs funny moment
was was was in the peak phase of crown
was november
november 2020 so belong there it
really went off and america travel impossible
and i still remember the situation i arrived
in washington at the airport and  got
off this plane and was all
alone and nobody else was
there in this huge hall because I
know they were graduates in washington
it's totally 70s so really
old-fashioned and everything so western from
yesterday yes but America yes and and then
I'll go through it  this hall and simply
no one there and then I kind of look
knew someone who lets me
in at immigration years ago
sat at the back in the
glass of coffee in here and I k  I went to him
and stayed to
fit in and so on and and also the
visa and he looks at me and says
you can't come in here
I say I have to go to an
interview what are you doing here says yes I
have an interview I don't have
said who should i don't know what to do with
the housing yes and said yes
to me better asked the former president
again and then he looks like that
and then it occurred to me thank god i
had such a cover letter the official
invitation from the team obama and  he was
still determined to send me
back then i got this
thing out and just pushed it
under this glass this glass
wall so look through it like that for 30 seconds
please say welcome it was very
funny to see what a
president like that does himself  former
president has and you have you
prepared yourself please we for a
chess game you don't do that more often
we are in the saying that  we
think about it i go in with the question
will i get the answer then i'll make
the move if i get the role
another move yes very deep yes
speak more precisely think exactly
there is actually the
preparation is 90% you can actually
throw it away and
then you just look where you know but
not exactly which 90 percent that's why
you always need the 114 preparations
that's the problem it
only gets difficult when you think both are playing
chess but the other one simply
knocks over the chess board and doesn't play,
then it gets difficult as well  the wendler back
then makes ok well so the choice was
wendler obama to 50
obama obama made me very obama was
interesting too that is maybe you
can tell again
diddy diddy the preparation yes what
happened before was totally interesting
we stood up to each other and had to
introduce it  Although so international
, the French were next door and
probably the Swedes and Kei on the left  no idea that's
a new
book his biography was published the
marketing of his biography and then
you have these hotel rooms in
wheaton america all always big one
after the other and he
just goes from sweet suite and that was crazy
i know exactly how it works you know  you
i know exactly the one just before you walk into this
room says first of all win
i'll meet right now and then he said
to me that's a guy from
germany you don't need to
know and interesting guy but his
name is what's more like markus
markus eicher okay and then he goes in
and says markus I'm not so happy
it's very casual and this whole thing and slow
casual because you expect of
course five
bodyguards to come first so contra secret
service etc. but nobody just came
the door went  up and he danced so
obama-like made the feeling I
immediately throws a basketball tencel because in there
says hello markus and he was
directly so that was on had
noted belongs to this you
're still a bit obama fans
too much it's okay it's okay yeah
that's yeah he's the thing is like
that through you know the
importance of this person  about the
historical significance of this person too,
you know, there is a global
icon right in front of you and the first
black president, so one way or
another, a very relevant man in the history books and also someone who always got
me, yes, so there was me  think it was
2004 it was in boston i forget
confused that always there was this
speech i think john kerry was the presidential candidate of
the democrats
and then obama appeared and the speech
i always recommend to
look at as a young politician
spoke there and has  saying that i'm
standing here tonight is against all
odds and then he
started to tell the
story of his family  and so
on and what the roots are
like and how improbable it really is
that someone like him is studying black at an
elite university that he is now standing
up here and has a vision of his
america is still presenting goosebumps
that is spectacular and you see that and know
after three minutes they were all
stunned and
probably asked themselves why we
weren't nominated and it was
clear then that the future president would speak it
was very clear
that not many people have that, he just
has incredible charisma  such an
incredibly sympathetic, approachable manner
and is just a nice person
and then has no inhibitions
then this this this human side is
probably rock hard there
you don’t have to fool yourself but this
human side then shows the humor
etc then told  how he
sometimes suffers from these famous ones
and sometimes in the oval office si  tzt or
saas and thought you know what I'm going to do
now, just sneak past the
secret service and then
I just kick out the
back door and disappear in this swarming
in the turmoil that was in
washington and and that describes exactly
that moment  in which he realized it
will not work
and then the much harder moment that
will never work again and who then
described it as she was later after the
end of his term of office with
michelle and his wife in piazza duomo milan
and goes out and the  just wanted to see
what would happen if they just
went out privately and were
then in a few minutes counted by 3000
people but that's no for you
Germany 900 but rather that
philipp is something that no
one can imagine so we won't
work  merkel is like that merkel is angela
merkel has now broken off her vacation in italy because from ward to ward
more and more people but i  st still
clearly different levels of course even if you are
now in berlin hamburg man in wales until
andy the match is exciting yes of course that
is but for the service
anyway it always depends how you have to
avoid certain things
so if you really  so
direct contact with people so then
you risk that at some point anger says
can take a picture i had my
wonderful scene in munich at the
airport a young man obviously of turkish origin came up
to
me and he was accompanied by his old
father who only spoke very rudimentary
german  classic
immigrants very nice people and the
young man stormed up to me and said
aren't you and so on and can
we take a picture and then
promise delivery the father said barbara take
a picture and the father takes
this cell phone in his hand and said dad
tom takes the picture and dad looks at it
and says why
i
just said look you should look at
yours  en
father he doesn't mind so well hey and
you say wrong no that's no I
have the topic so difficult a people
if people complain about it you know
how bad it would be if nobody wanted
to talk to you please get rid of
them  we don't have anything to do is probably
what the reason i didn't do social
media cars but what i
want no longer yes that's one
reason the other reason is also i
honestly just don't have the time
and
i have to  concentration
you probably experience that too i think
that the danger of getting bogged down is enormous
and the more it gets and the
bigger the wheel gets that you turn like this,
the more you really have to
concentrate i don’t think
that’s true if that’s the case  investigations
that as human beings we were once able
to really concentrate our 12 seconds
on one thing
and
now we're at 8 i think
and it's getting bad w  If you know that
new goldfish can use
instagram again, for example,
then you are
probably already aware of that, some of you are also
really photographer, filmmaker, yes, also
very good at it, and that is why
instagram would actually be for that, since we
live there, so to speak, but exactly yes
well, i think i've always found
that you have to do that, so to speak,
then maybe you understand it then
with is he so explain i have
about 60 70,000 black and white photos
at home of people who at some point were in
that he
and i photographed  people always
say yes after the show and then the creators say
ok, they
're going to make a book project out of it and so on, but the
truth is I'm only doing it for myself
and at some point because there are so many by now maybe it will become
a
book but me  I think it's
important that there are things that you
only do for yourself,
and we don't do that much
enough, we knock  everything always depends on what
brings me what happens then but
i deeply believe that this
also applies to children, by the way, you also have children
it's not great when you
see how children can lose themselves so completely in the game
and when  then the
sentence comes dad i'm bored
you've heard that too then it
just gets interesting then you have to
let them and say yes that's how it is then
have to deal with it now and then they
start to occupy themselves on the beach or
at home or no matter where  and then you
start to get really creative and
this freedom that's what we had at the
beginning of the conversation that that's
the blatant
opposite to what we discussed
, with a 60 percent
probability of earning 800,000 online for two
minutes  yes that's the
opposite of that and i think that
people also like their mask and rich
people i think that
they take a lot from it the d  hey they just let themselves be carried along
and think, they
take the freedom to think completely
independently, they are of course completely unfounded, of course, they
also use it on twitter and soy yes yes yes exactly they
use it etc. there is
no question but that is the reason and
on twitter for example
would  I find it difficult for myself because
I somehow have to
try to maintain a certain neutrality,
which is of course important,
so again hot positions from so easy,
but it's really general but
still interesting, so twitter is
really opinion-forming,
I personally war again and again  so
i'm on the road relatively little i
really like to read long texts and
twitter
but
it's something to do and say yes there are
only a few thousand people and they
determine the public discourse
but what kind of people who are so similar
to the economic  podcast do you know who's
listening to who's writing and of
course it's interesting solid difficult
neutral  al to be on the show so when
you
say obama was good at the time, are you actually trying to
be neutral yes
well yes exactly obama is now trying
to find the critical appendix so to speak and to ask him how
it is  with the drones and yes and just to
know now you are killing people i
mean the operations of the americans in the
last decades especially in the middle
east have produced more taliban
and islamists than anything else
yes you just have to
realize that it is his  Speechwriter
ben rhodes pointed this out again
and said a lot of
crap is being built and you
can discuss that with him too you can't do
everything in detail in such a
short slot it takes half an hour
and then he's gone but  in
principle i think you
always have to keep this independence i
also know tony blair then i
asked whyu  m the autobiography and
then at some point i got him thinking
he had me so casually in his sack and how it
kept pointing out that i had a
cooking show and so on
and then he also tried to throw me
completely off my head because
he was about to  at the beginning of the conversation
he suddenly looked at my shoes and
i said okay in the reboot in austria but
that has a completely different background he
just didn't want to get out of step
what the cooking show so i made a
cook like that everything was clear and we did that
and then  and he often didn't take me
seriously, and rightly so, up to the point at
which i asked
you why you actually
converted to catholicism to
confess the crap you were doing in
iraq and then he went forward and
then it notices okay it starts to
work and then started to keep addressing me by my
first name says yes know
markus know and so on and then I knew
okay now jet  currently happening
okay you are so interesting because you are generally
looking for such interviews because the
feedback via twitter is not open
so much but there is but i
get the rent it is not so
that i that that is again crass
things but  right away there were
interviews with sahra wagenknecht after
there was a petition against you signed by over
100,000 people because you
actually asked them too critically that
's exactly what it was but at the time it was totally unavoidable
to find everything stupid that i
did insofar as it was  the hard time that
we have to go back to the biography because
we just stopped radio
then you are on the radio then radio in
tyrol and on the radio to hamburg and then
to tv in cologne yes tv
only to hamburg here there is klaus
ebert us the white one  house celebrated there
you can too klaus is a very,
very important person in my life recently called him again
and stuff like that and ha  t given
me the chance back then when i was at
radio hamburg i say yes
i wasn’t there very long
then they kicked me out
because but i made this song i
often told their story and stuff like that and
then you urgently need a
firefighter it’s a lot  bigger says jan
the connection use for the young
volunteer and klaus ebert gave me
the chance to come to rtl that
was of course great that i would then work
from rtl north in hamburg to
cologne exactly exactly then but
at least switched to the public one
exactly me  if i'm being completely honest i
always wanted to go there and
not just anywhere but exactly to the zdf
ok why was i know maybe
it's the stockholm syndrome i have
in south tyrol in the valley there was only the
zdf at my house in other valleys
there was only the a
d we only had the zdf that's why
i say stockholm syndrome i always
watched a colt just in case and  trio
with four fists so that was for me
that the df as a child and that's why
i liked and still like the zdf
i have because i've really
never regretted it i have but also have to
say the colleagues from rtl at least
as much  heart is closed it was
that was that was the shop where i
actually appreciate everything really
very much the zdf some mountains and valleys and
mountains again and there
comes a real quality into play how
much and how long people stay
and that is  but they are like that
and we all depend on them all of us
that's why I'm always a
bit humble because I always say
don't fly so high my little friend
you know don't freak out here
now because the day when you
'll need them all again  it's coming and we
shouldn't be so presumptuous as to
believe that we can do it alone,
we all
depend on people who catch us at the
right moment
stay on our side and if it gets difficult
we'll still say no matter we'll pull through together back
then the thing with values that didn'
really work at le
st in the public in the publi
hed perception above all the z
f remained very clear on my side and that
hat's that  that's big
we want to bet that it's a
little bit too so that she needs you that was
for most situations
exactly doing that for gottschalk was gone too
and then you completely pick up the story yes
i've been following it and then i've followed it
up now  did someone ask
you a little
too much about doing that or
did you say gail the question me now
is my look yeah that's
just standing the same way that was it was
actually you see what i
'm doing that what  i'm doing it now
that's what i like to do best and
also at a late hour and so i
've i never really enjoyed it
g  somehow
dreams of coming down the stairs for a show and the mdr tv ballet is dancing in the
background
it was that was never really my big
dream not at all and i'm incredibly
grateful that i'm allowed to do what i
do then
you're allowed to follow that now you're paid for it that's
really interesting  currently that many
from the public sector are
now starting to go back to the
private ones so linda
zervakis has never done that before i think it will be done afterwards
so a
lot of people are now going this way
with you don't ask me now if
money is important  I'm quite sure no,
but there will also be talks with you
. RTL Kinder has one
person in common. I suspect that people
will ask you from time to time whether you would
like to play because of the role, but that's
not an issue [music] for you,
so it
really is  is it that i
follow with great interest what
my colleagues at rtl are doing
right now stefan schäfer
knows hotelch  ef yes and the hostel for
your eyes house and very interesting
media person i think and i
think it's good what they are doing there also what
they are trying to do seriously
in this area the
interesting thing is yes philipp it
always sounds like that and it is often used in the media
too  presented in such a way that rtl would now
try a big information offensive, so to speak, and
now we want to
be more or less serious is nonsense the truth of
rtl was there before they were there already
think of the great successes of hans
mahr peter kloeppel and others
exactly that  systematically exactly günther jauch
at stern tv this systematically
raised
and were then really on par with the
public service and in
some cases even better and faster
than the public service thereby
interestingly also made the other
system better because it
is a
I think the competition was very, very good for all of
us  ern is it really just
a return to old
roots i would say and of
course you recognize the people it's
a small scene and so on but
i just said somehow you know
that you should never be forgotten
you always have to  the ones who understand their own
situation
exactly the program we are doing now
works there in this context in
this slot exactly with this
station with this audience
i don’t think it has that
much to do with me
the editors after great work
if really  good people and they
try incredibly hard and
then they always fall a bit more
original than maybe others but
that never really means oneself
that you always have to know if at all
means is a function but
that's the way you always are a
little bit until you  but relaxed
you write but yes I think if you
now
even your I don't really live much
i  Isn't one really my deep
conviction that and that the
media history is full of such
examples of people who believe you
just change the channel
and the audience just goes
automatically that's not true that
it's presumptuous johannes b kerner who
was  yes, so to speak, in your zloty hau you
at zdf and then changed
then almost no longer returned to the old
relevance i would
say now it was always
known that was but i think that was
a decision that johannes made very
consciously  johannes had
a great career really great
career thinks his whole
sport was banned and i think he was
just a bit open at some point
so it's exhausting when you do so
many productions johannes
i mean now what he says four
shows per  week he just lived through
that he would soon have lived by him
he has it now al  les a
sports studio alex and i think johannes
just wanted to work a little less at some point
and
i understand that too but it's still i want to
learn a bit as a cautionary
example that you can't just
change like that because at the time
this club also believed in something like that
maybe yes, that's
exactly it, but i wouldn't
attach it to johannes so much right now because that
's i think one of the background
was a different decision made by
others, but in principle it's
still right that the audience
doesn't just go along with it  goes from there I am
absolutely convinced again you can
then keep going that’s
our concentration and the output and
that’s already considered racist
you’re doing it very focused and say
that’s high-performance sport yes yes
so I would say that it’s still but not the
end  for the foreseeable future of ten years, so
if you don't tell me now, watch
out, I'll have them e  not keen
on his visage anymore then i would
say i'll go on a bit more
so that we that's that it's still 1
degree as exciting that's also interesting by the way that's
why i meant the
context you only know that at a time when
mario barth
had to mention the word handbag and everyone went nuts
yes someone like me would definitely not have worked
that way you know what i
mean now we have completely different times
now says mario barth handbags and
no one freaks out anymore at the moment he
has it has everything his phases mario
does  still his things and they are
successful so everything is fine but i just
want to say the zeitgeist has
changed because the problems the
challenges are completely different we
had the pandemic we have
what we talked about at the
beginning we globalization has many
many
good times  understand for his show
exactly good times to explain things
good time-critical also hard questions
make good times to just
go and i'm also sometimes like that that's
why i sometimes
slide around on the chair yes and now
almost every day a signpost from the south
german newspaper with the grill tongs
then slipped forward and it will be expensive
more
aggressive yes yes  yes i
just want the conversation
partner to feel my breath
speak a little unfortunately thinks okay
no no why because you have the feeling
no it is difficult for you to
argue and you made the
mistake and you don't want to do it
if  you actually have one now
but it's yes no it's
so i think it's really a
political discussion and arguing
must also be possible and people
can all do that
essay they're professionals and they really have what
it takes and my question is simple,
so to speak  to find the right question for each answer the
his task is
the other yes but you will now play a
role h  at us
to find the right answer to every question that's the
game but you've also
become a political talk show again that's
how broad the
media used to be and does he turn exactly in the
dealers and family mature so we had there
we've had guests for two years
now but that's not the case anymore so
now you're really into
politics actually we have the feeling
that people isn't just politics is
also economics everything is possible
but it's already it's
social politics the  the
viewers are expecting that i think because they
are looking for that it will be there
again look at those that
worked well yesterday like yes absolutely of course
we get that very
well we get it every day
like that the curves now see something  happens
but it depends on the opening act
right against the unbelievable yes he
absolutely yes it's so isolated but ok
so with all the opposite program delay guest
o  the guests exactly that's just the
curves when when when you see the curve
and it goes up like that
then you know okay that's someone the
people wanted now either
makes a curve up like
that richard markus söder makes the murderer curve up
wanted to see if i so there was
definitely a time when you wanted to do an autopsy in
erbach yes karl lauterbach
also the trade context so karl
lauterbach was the corona explain to the
nation and people wanted to be karl
lauterbach is that’s the way it is
but mine  I that's always just the time
the earlier with is means low is
meant the function it's a borrowed curve, so to speak,
that doesn't
necessarily mean Bavarian inheritance law
is so that the one who built up a
community yes said but
also but also so richard  is a
perfect explainer of the world so that and
that in the context richard is absolutely
brilliant and that's why it worked and
we're still here on opinions  tarken is
someone i don't know very many people who,
how should you put it, are so independent in
their thinking that's why i envy him
sometimes
i consider myself to be someone who is also
relatively independent and that's
why not so many social media because
when i start that  to read everything carefully and
even to comment then
i think i would start
to restrict myself at some point to
control you have to be willing
to jump in size with a start yes if
you if you are not ready to
do that night after night and can say
i go home that you
also know some people if i do this now
i probably get somewhere in
me have media or
something history asks again exactly if i
do this now i get it straight
away and then it has to
be
like you see  you because the genesis of the
podcast meanwhile your or your race has been an amazing success so
we can talk a bit with it
produce and so we had that
once too nice i do that i
discussed together in the end it was of
course your idea to do something like
that and i think i had a very
specific idea to ask richard that the
story is how he had it after a
show  we were still sitting together
and within sight of the famous
bären teller what i you know the
stories
they had in bärenthal there was a very nice portrait
by markus feldenkirchen about karl
lauterbach but there is a video that you think is
with the ndr i definitely have it
seen the case and it was really very good
and when asked what he likes about our
show, karl lauterbach says he
doesn’t expect anything in terms of content
says well i like the bear plate that is
in markus lanz’s room
i find it
afterwards alone fruits fresh fruits
and
you  can't imagine
since then at least once a
week someone comes by and says oh that's
the basf soga  r people who do self how to do it with
the plate of honor
says the whole year how exactly we sat
together and it was the topic podcast
and so on didn't tell him that
we're thinking about it and you know
he hesitated for a long time to do it and he
also but the  then counted i'm also thinking
about it right now and so because that's just an
interesting conversation format
and then we sat there and thought about it back and
forth and at some point i said
maybe we can do it
together maybe that'll be an
idea it was that's what it's all about
to do something really different
and then there is always the difficulty
when you do something like this in pairs you
have to like each other somehow
no you can't just do it again
only a bare calculation works for me
but you have to watch I want to
go with you  these people spend time
together like we both
do now you know that works because we
kinda like each other so i like you  h on
[laughter]
and that's the point and then you have to be
ready somehow yes that but
we approached it very humbly I
we were very surprised that
what it was like that is also
spoken together yes exactly I was worried because
you  both yes no social media
we made a big podcast also experience that
they in organists exactly where we are
the medium actually not at all etc. it
is so that you can point out the podcast
that's okay i'm
on instagram or twitter a
lot now  big don't point to my
podcast in that both didn't
say so okay how will the potters be
discovered if the two ca
n't point to anything at all about larger
ranges and what was appreciated
here is that you can see but
you look like clips  by richard or where
you can be seen on youtube that
's a normal clip in the vitra profi
richard quite a guest somewhere but
somehow it's already exactly 300,000  off and
there is a real community and
I say that in the end you're right you
're doing it's really exactly
a podcast how much from Austria
and for how long you
've been doing more work than you
think people think yes  also ne
acceptable also on tv they
sit chatting a bit but
actually you have to be quick is
and don’t write it to you like that but
we talk briefly about the topic
we vote briefly and really
mostly via sms i was constantly
somehow  on the road and I also have a
lot to do and then I think
we both prepare relatively intensively for it
because you can't deal with numbers, then they
handle facts
that set the mood
so carefully because we're watching a show like that from
dierig  now watch like that depending on the 1.52
million people how many hours
does your work include in his show
to be honest that's what
i think  ch a bit like you
philipp i didn't
really know how to say the hours the truth is
actually the work never stops you
're actually always there i left
mine today yeah exactly me i read
everything online everything
i never have in the newspaper in my hand
so i'm really glad about it i
kinda don't want it anymore i don't know
why but i love it that's why i love
being able to read smartphones all the time
and i deal
with topics that sometimes
have nothing to do with the matter at all  and
at some point you might
be able to pull it out again so that is and what is
very, very broad what kind of
an economical product is a show so you
sell it in the end a zdf just
produced in your own brut so
then he
played an important role there  even
with markus i always have the feeling that
when we get together it's the same
as with richard and it's 1 and 1 3
and that's good
actually that was an idea of zdf manni
teupen he has the former head of enter
ainment who s
ill writes to us from time to time etc.
est regards at that point very
ice man who kille
such a guy at the time yes w
ll markus actually had marku
yes, this vessel i came to
it because the traffic is exactly
planning schmidt etc. markus is like that too
we are both in a certain way
and that also applies to richter
and i think even to you in
a totally old-fashioned way
classic journalistic approach speech
counter-speech look at what happens
with the not be satisfied with the first answer
sometimes the exciting approach
for the for a new story for a
topic is not at the beginning of a long piece
but at the very back of the last
paragraph it is sometimes the thought
in it you think that's it and so
and yes and that's why
markus works  assisch from journalism that
means there I think
then it is also exactly what all that
is there that the whole thing and on these
common processes and then there is
also from the ruhr area that comes on top of that
because of the life year for me the
most exciting people  in
germany i didn't have to no
but i really mean it like that there
you have one they always have such a
snout we have a hotspot they
dare what they are so direct
that for me is so elke heidenreich you
know so
berghaus and then  think about what you
're actually being said so would be hand in a way the old saying moderator then yeah like that pastor would be standing but okay we're happy that
doesn't matter because no job does them all totally
so completely more ruhr area is not possible
but let's say you're in
then met the constituency together
in the 25 because of two markus
different positions we are
not only allowed to or one but then that is
as a flagship w  probably that with
them you really do but also
cooking shows the power of the kitchen battle
you have everything exactly everything happened
on the railings exactly you are
then in these shows little little we
do we really take care of
everyone, so to speak, then about their topics
marcus held then  his area together
and then to be honest i'm
really very focused on the show
was for that internally on the podcast yes
and that is also in truth the podcast is yes
even if the show that means
that then four a week that's fine
you have to  you have to stay tuned and do
n't let yourself be distracted otherwise
it won't work and
then sell every show to zdf and
say somehow that such a show has been used and
you've billed it because he yes
i think it runs roughly that yes i
don't know that exactly do you know
that  we really produce very cheaply,
but it is also not a man who
now looks closely at what is his
own sho  w what's good no not at all
we have good people there and they
calculate that it's also
all very transparent how
it works it's not a big secret it
then comes down to what what
then simply makes up the success and then also
at some point economic success
is simply the frequencies
we just work a lot, 140
productions a year so do
140 times the iranian one and that is
and then the whole team like
this exactly so markus then with
his whole cooking area and so on
also does a lot, but
especially this show
shouldn’t correspond to a finding that
’s 140 very well now
we have to do it first and then we’ll talk
to have space together we
really have a great team because
it goes from the editorial department
to the whole t  technical trades
line up the people who sit in the director's
office the people behind the cameras
stormed in several Lena masks
yes that's all people would
then really boot up the thing
then then it starts and it
works like clockwork
something else is taking effect, so to speak,
that above all, markus is really well
positioned, what if we have a summer party
, we're already shooting for several
hundred people, absolutely exactly that
means a show, even people who don't work
for us, they sneak up there
just so pure
but you know that we give each other good
food but yes and delivers in the clock
zdf has other channels so
you also do production for anja sofia for
a tv go along with the story and and
for our story that well I am
above all things  tied exclusively to the zdf
okay that's not what
different after herr do you have
to ask everything and now somehow not appear
in the ard  or something like that and you are
an example and you are somehow also
so focused that if you follow that
you hardly appear anywhere else in hamburg or in general in
public you hardly do anything else
actually
you are in hamburg there is also
a little please  sometimes invited here
and there you are not nowhere that
is already conscious that so that goes in
the opening of that or that yes exactly
i suspect that you would like to have you everywhere
but you are very reserved yes
yes yes to be honest yes i
might have  also to do with it i like
this loud performance not so far so
that's not mine so this oops
here come on like that was never really my
topic and i how much then
mostly the time i have to make up your mind
you have to decide  in life,
as you know, and if you have a lot of
opportunities to realize yourself professionally
, as is
fortunately the case with me, then
you have to be careful that something special
For example, it's also time to use the
children again, don't get under your wheels
, it's important to pay attention and
there is also a legend about you that
you keep fit very professionally
and are physically fit and I
heard so push ups, push-ups, 300
pieces  every day he told what that
told me lars haider from the
hamburger abendblatt the editor-in-chief
who i think is also trying to
get to know each other better so lars haider that
is so you can mention it briefly
there is writing a book
i had to say, on the other hand, the
declared will  about my explained where
i find that unbelievable but i said to
myself don't make yourself
unhappy back then they were only by
you but he just does it now i
can't prevent it
if i could i would do it immediately
but like before brother  shot
written by lars i think there is
now a book about olaf scholz
he knows olaf scholz quite well at 3
in  in the book by lars halter there
is a really interesting sentence about
olaf scholz he says olaf scholz is
to the point of painful i
kite shy medium yes and then
you think wait a minute okay and then
you will become federal chancellor i.e. how does that work
together i think that goes together
and i think that both are right so
the will to become chancellor and
at the same time is shy so she is
very nice a lot when you see how good
explaining and observing lars haider can be
so harder than up to his
subject yes i have  afraid but there are
push-ups is there is but
he still has it a place so i wo
n't tell him he's not
there for the interrogation but in fact
it's like that i try every day i'll do
my sports program in we
and yes  it may be that I come
up with something similar,
it may have to be, but if that
was very easy back then in the wedding league
, I have it
not done it yet i started it
because i got problems with
my back it's easy
but even back then when we bet that
you were pretty fit yes i
did other sports i did a
lot of endurance sports i'm
such a runner me  need that i have
to really sweat once a day and then
you run ten kilometers yes that is exactly at the
moment i have i
injured a knee at
christmas while skiing
after 20 seconds on the ski slope
you have to follow that first and that’s why
it’s not like running at the moment  so
easy but coming back
soon have to reckon with the fact that i will be
back at the start here often yes
exactly it is already on the map i
am so fast it
is not really relaxed
you are amok hamburg is a
really relaxed city here  there
are so many people alive who are so much
better known than me, please,
no, but serious people, they have so much  e
hits not at all in germany so
have kept close saw educational level
and are really so we have to say yes
i can judge myself that way but
i would have a north german heart
and a bit distant and not
now it seems it is probably
in the ruhr area because that  what other servers
markus because it's the sun so exactly
so there's a
gradation so the hamburgers if they speak to
you will have one in
munich in munich is right
away their service markus you do it you're there
right away use what i really use  maybe because here
in tyrol we always use first-name
terms and only in cologne there are dozens who
can touch
it i like but it's also going to be like that precisely
because lasalle's book are curious
also somehow actually
probably you're
not trying too hard now you want to
try it  a book you
actually wrote a book about
the chef horst lichter, yes, i
'm quite happy with it  address that
was it was very interesting at the time
i was very how should you say formative
for me because i was 27 it came out
i don't think so exactly and
there was a there was a request from a
publisher Gütersloh publishing house
that is the nucleus of bertelsmann
the  had read a text of mine somewhere
i don't even know where and
then said if i
somehow they seem to be able to write a bit
and so on they don't want to do
a book for us and then
the idea in the room something with media was
closer than or  classics and i
have absolutely no interest in that
really nobody cares
if a
tv film is now written about tv who wants to know
and then my colleague ulrich cloos has a
very good nice colleague from rtl with
whom i worked very closely at the
time it was one of
my dvds  manager on duty and said to
me you there is a totally
interesting guy horst lights that
i'm going to cook etc. the w  at that time in the
rhineland he was such a national celebrity
and
just started to do a bit of
television more and more and also a
bit kerner i think and he
said he has an interesting story and
uli is someone who had and still has a feeling for good stories
and
then i started to
deal with it and then told the publisher
i have a story for you
and then it was very interesting they said
it won't work because
it's not known throughout germany and so
on and i then said what
to do  your entrepreneurial decision
i either make this book or no
book simply because i was deeply
convinced that this
story works and therefore
formative because it has confirmed that
there is nothing people are more
interested in than the stories of
others and it is completely  no matter if they are
famous people or not
famous people and i  it doesn't matter at all
i think anyway that we always
completely overestimate that they have to have
big names and big people who no is
because someone who can tell something is someone
who has something to tell puts that on
track then that works and that's
horst lichter  usually an unbelievable
talent when it comes to that and i then
really accompanied and observed for
months and although there wasn't where
i worked for rtl on the side i was the
editorial manager
behind the scenes worked very actively for it
made the show every day and wrote
this book at night and  i
still remember when i wrote the first
chapter and then i
obviously got tired from
4 in the morning and fell my head on the keyboard
and hit the backspace button
when i woke up he was still standing r
all gone who was your story was
that  story and then I wake up
and think he wasn't
really awake and think oh okay wait a minute
I got everything  saves now if i
just open
it again everything is back because i press
the cross windows at the top and then he asks what
do you want to save what do i do that
first saved then everything was gone when
i woke up stood provider of this r
that was so hard and  then i wrote
everything again until half past seven in the morning
was better too and took a
shower and was allowed to go to work
oh wow so i worked
so you still have days like
that so yes yes yes if you dream
of working you have to work
it's really different like how many hours in the day
sometimes you go to
bed like you know if you do too sometimes
we do two productions a day
or so then and then you really
somehow get to bed at 2 or so then
finally slowly to bed you
can't you go to sleep right away
because you still have dietmar bartsch in your ear
who thanked the usa quite
officially which of course was a
big deal  nsation is that I am one of the left
party in the usa he said thank you as
calm also so he didn't
really say thank you but it was a bit
that was very funny moments now there were
in the show yesterday but did you just
realize if that's a great
moment  now i created the big one
who wanted it that
was just entertaining moment but
yes if there is a big moment you
understand that is interestingly
me but talked to phil collins about
how that is he phil collins was used to be
with us has  also made a
biography and i then asked him if
you know as a musician at this level
that you have when you put in the studio
said you know that maybe
yes he knows that there is envy he knows the
thing that will also be like that that means  that
a guest but you know that if you
know exactly when some situation happens in the
show and you know it
happens now sometimes there is still
silence  that you simply had to endure
are still there when I get
the question now not
difficult for me to answer but
nevertheless certainly now through it there are
still people like that they are
already predestined because with you in the
show
as before
Mrs. Merkel has been there and so far
not much has been done with you yes exactly I
mean as chancellor you have that is also
now with olaf scholz there I have a
bit of a locational disadvantage we are
in hamburg it is not that easy
then always  for a chancellor
you know already annoyed that
the first merkel talks after her term in
office it has now mirror
alexander osang i think they know
each other well for a long time you also wrote a
book you thought man
she could have done that with us too
so  Always a warm welcome of course it
could have been done but please
so it's totally fine i also
understand why you di  ese form world
is also nice
to do it in such a theater and still know that
it would be heard i mean angela merkel
don't have to prove anything to anyone anymore but of
course it's still interesting to
see how the people themselves look at it when they are in office
and then
say but are there others from angela
merkel that would be helpful if they
came or that would be us
here again yes the
whole russia policy, for example
angela merkel about her, it is always said that she
was one of the few who
really understood like this putin  is ticking and what
does that have to do with your gdr past
yes i believe that was also
described in relation to the chinese
communist party and i said i am
sitting across from it and i know
exactly what he thinks i know exactly what he is like
because that is this this  this
year the old cadres they know exactly how
it works and i
think putin ii also has illusions
about it  made as it really is but
if that's the case then you don't have to
say why then
this depends yes why
and I think we would have to
work on something yes that means
merkel would still be really exciting
and still nine people  so any
alone wildcard jan gerd schröder
i would have similar questions for example exactly
is a national politician or other
politicians you somewhere don't have an
eye on surprising people from the niche topic
if i started now i would
really be a little after so i
envy  you around then talking to uli
hoeneß is by the way highly recommended
yes super thank you who really yao
lifa payroll of the suppliers is 0 increase at all
i would really
like to keep that we do the best
received then you say we tried again and
again but didn't
work  But I'll do it someday
, maybe you can come up with a good
word for  michael i like to try yes well
it means invited to the show yes
yes exactly and that was also the
difficult time and so on and then
you don't want
to expose yourself but i want hoeness yes i'm feeling so today that
i'm just calling here
if you also good well also a man
with the madness i can't
just do that on the cell phone as
medium another miracle have to
come back meanwhile that's not
history absolutely what medium
hope I had the first interview with him
after his stay in prison  yes yes
and then you also notice what has so
to speak do you know this famous
photo thomas middelhoff clear what should
so thought what also like yes exactly
tells yes like but it is really
nourishing it was so the photo is
also me with him  home is the photo
explained in detail by annie leibovitz
photographed the photographer at a
conference in the usa where they are called by the
rally conference they come from
the investment bank invited the
very biggest that's why valley
has been together for decades and that was back
then, the time of the acquisition my boss
was invited because he
also plays the role in slocan valley
and bill
gates of the young bosses
steve jobs was invited too  jobs jobs exactly all in
this photo 3
all are david from the class photo so
this caliber next to it was thomas
gehring behind him i think i
read i read it like this
and then i think the guy
from yahoo is sitting on his white
moldy background he knows yes
now i'm not so present now but
these photos just impress they are
simply the greatest tech bosses
there are on this planet yes that's
very interesting to listen to thomas middelhoff as he
talks about how the young jeff bezos traveled to
gutersloh to convince bertelsmann of
that  to buy shares in amazon
because he urgently needs investors and
money and has what  test yes
want to do he says yes so go so i
think that's right because the cdu
credible yes and why that here
also very
exactly how have yes yes yes he
was always the roja google
yes yes exactly exactly and then he tells
like jeff  bezos from amazon at that time he
still packed his packages himself
together with steve case so you
are in the digital business
after all and like jeff bezos who
also packed the books himself at the time being important
with his wife
was a  book club actually not
and that's why they
thought amazon thought book club created and so
it somehow fits together well
there I'm going to reach the next
level totally crazy and then he
tells how he arrives with the
backpack and with such bad
jeans  and a white t-shirt and
they're just like that and then you meet
all these managers in pinstripes and so
on and they say we're not
interested is she h  ätten correctly
buy shares that is there is a
parallel story so who as a man
does not take shares in amazon there is
a story that google or
also had google too i think there was
also the possibility to invest in google once
bertelsmann year
also rejected it  well i know the
dieburg story the holtzbrinck
story became holtzbrinck also
bought toys back then the gate in
london had where facebook
according to legend if i was there
facebook offered to holtzbrinck e-mail
so to speak for studivz or for the joint german business
somehow i think  i got up to 10
percent from facebook back then you
would only have had to bring it in asleep
that would of course be the case today i
think facebook is worth 600 billion
it will be 60 billion that would be just
you bring wood you made this trade back
then you said
foggy power  prefer to do it alone and we think
we're here  inside in germany
i mean daimler sold the
shares in tesla for
the money too so the economy is really
exciting we have super exciting it
makes it totally interesting because you say
how much money investment so if you
earn money as ten shares share
so  that we ourselves also campaigns
campaigns but also directly in companies
for a year you can say what
kind of things I really like at
a price the
[laughter]
the classic apple facebook alphabet er
clear meters and so clear so you also have
over the  grown in the last few years it's
getting longer yes and
then that's the thing itself long ago
they explain they I think now
I'll say things again that I
really like at a price that I like
and then I just leave it be
but of course it comes  because not every
day not at all but say that's because of
the same if you will you say
von buffett of course that a company
that one likes is  very easy to say what
you like but also really like the price
you can understand yes that's
the great art and that's why
the suitcase facebook page price doesn't
like that assumes that you
really understand what kind of rating
is as just fair  what is cheaper
than expensive exactly that's why i'm
always crazy so please don't
get me wrong now i don't give
any investment publicly at all because in
the end it's of course always
a risk and like a banker friend of
mine always tells me it's only over
at zero
yes that's how it is  if things aren't going well then things are going
pretty well and then you'll have
bad luck very quickly that's why I won't tell you
what's up with this or that
but there are so many interesting things
and I think we need them but it
happened the young people in particular are
now the rediscovered yes the share
again must be very precise and it is such
a pity that actually through this whole
dot-com bubble at that time the di  In the
noughties, an unbelievable number of
people got trampled under their wheels at the time,
exaggerated in every direction, I know,
there were people lying around in the corridors of rtl
and between one cut and the
next people whispered
some names said I'll do it,
you have to buy it  then continue
then make a contribution and then go out again in the
next café break emphasizes again that,
by the way, those were also companies
that sometimes had a garage and
sometimes didn’t even have that and
they bought it and then you
rolled the performance to
14,000 percent plus and  so on and
I always thought yes and then
sold rather my 14001 sold
but just
have to wait and so on then it
slowly went down needed remember that
was very interesting that wasn’t that
wasn’t a bubble that just
burst but it worked  Yes, relatively
slowly, bit by bit,
like salami, that wasn't a horror
crash overnight and I remember  and
that's interesting with people then
there are
losses it's going down it's going down it's
going and then says yes now i'm
only 12,000 percent up and sold
but now they'll come back
you're sure yes yes 8000 percent up
sold but now you have  you still
make 8000 namely and then but now
i'm only 100 percent in plus
now i can't sell but
now you doubled your bet
they sold then at 200
percent - and that's just it or with a
total loss it's just yes that's it  that's
awesome what if you're
not god-given in this role
so far grown into it but suddenly
you're on this mountain, so to speak,
that of the German television range
and explaining the news and
so many others are no longer we
had one  Spiegel boss certainly
still has his options,
then I no longer think of so many
owners
choosing topics or t  choice of topic being
able to control so much communication in
our country so off its politics
scares me hate anger all of a
sudden you're almost alone there yes that's
honestly not true at all
so there are all the
others who do the same thing  well
there is not such a
great level there but there are the
other talk shows 12 maybe but
fuller yes actually I
also like these these descriptions that
you just gave yes
I don't see myself at all not at all
I think  the editors don't see themselves that
way either, we just do our work in a very
banal way and as technically consistent as possible
that's all
why did you have the
episodes uploaded to youtube at the same time
yes i can't say that for legal
reasons
i can't say they were
always wechselberg  again about content
so that they just take everything that way
somehow that was it too
mathias döpfner also
not only said a lot of clever things but also moved them there
you look at that this is a topic for
you streaming platforms so
netflix and their production is
it too yes
i think you have to be careful
not to get bogged down
there  but we are not yet so
that you say as active as i think
you could actually be
and his cooking show that you ended
up cooking so lanz was actually
held such people as tony blair
we don't have more free time now
not at all i really liked doing it and really like
to think back to that
time but it was just then
still told just over you
know then i felt yes that is much
more precise yes exactly that was then what
at some point you have in everyone  pot once
looked in at some point you
always tried every sauce and so on and it was
also a revelation every time and i
like the kitchen are what you are good at
the cook so change so much and he
's a very good eater that's
really what would be yes yes totally me
but I never cooked there
either the show was called search wisely lanz cooks
but
actually it should have been called quite
lets cook god be  thanks the
others cooked that you don't want to
eat what i'm cooking but the the the
cooks themselves have always fascinated me
because they are so completely
independent personalities
fascinating people busy almost
where the people today for you is
actually the last  level what
you can achieve now is
just make even more progress and over
the long term is a kind of legend or should become a
legend you have now
done it in 30 years as you
can yes obama is now had the show
has  the relevance is
actually now just say
a lot of consistency and
frequency just keep going by surfing that's
that's the performance a  lso then says
'you know what the interesting
thing is philipp and i think there is
a parallel between the two of us again i
've never seen it like that or you
never planned it that way but things happen
i always believed in hard work
and i have  always
believed that you really have to
make an effort sometimes
certain points are always gone and everything else
happens then that's what i
said at the beginning that bothers me
totally this especially with our
children we shouldn't do that we
should I  say that and then
happens b and then happens like this and so
it goes on god how boring
is that how terribly boring would
you have ever thought that you would be sitting here
and so that you can't but that's
driving again in the end and
it was the same for me  that happened to me yes i
know i started out here in hamburg
in an advertising agency and there
was the boss back then i went there
I think I earned 6,000 marks
and then I said I'm quitting now I
'm going to radio hamburg I'm doing
an internship there and then he said yes okay
I'll give you 7,000 I don't
want him we're talking about an
annual salary or a monthly salary but
I like 707,000  really
earned money oh
really well 6000 i earned
offers me 7000 that got me then he
says something what do you get there now
then i say like 300 and he says like that a day
never a month
and then doesn’t say anything anyway and
then a pause and then he said
i've never seen anyone
who has ruined their career like we
are right now and
then you sit there and think what if
he's right but i just did it
it was a total risk  from
today's point of view one can say very
easily say yes did everything right
from the point of view of the time catastrophe but i
just did it i really wanted to
do it his relationship with
s  agen we at zdf there is a
you and there is also a big
face to say unfortunately towards you
have an exchange regularly you are
how should you lose
she also works a lot we
once had an interesting exchange as you
know exactly  the podium per tier and
will go beyond the limits because yes it
really broke it and i have
so you can look it up on
youtube that well well that is exactly what it is there to
see then it was about the key word
if balance and it was  interesting
but i see i follow what powers
you we do some really
really good stuff seems to have
a great great reaction and
i think we who have been
consistently delivering consistently well for
many years are the people it is
already today and it  is comedy or if you
look you can always see there is
also a very deep political
understanding then
markus helped me unbelievably i know now  t this
is going to be a big podcast of the five
hundredths
so thank you very much for coming
that you have now warm studies
meanwhile is
really what you have done well i would say
that climate change is progressing
today we definitely
trained for that bench trained for a
degree of global warming we are here today to
put the camera just with this
heat you inside you now open
the temperature lag what is the hague
to become really something that that is
really i tell you that is the biggest
thing we have to deal with is  so
absolutely yes that's the big thing
and we have to get
that under control and you'll also notice the frustration of the young
people they're hot for us
boomers we're kicking ass
because they say we've gathered it
and they've got it  not really so what
can you do what can you do yes we have to do it
now we really have to get down to it and we have to do
everything that is technically feasible
en and we have to now
I'll tell you where to
pinch and let's get started it's now the new building
has that's completely impossible that
the pipeline will blow us up what
you immediately have you got there such a narrative it
would be that terrorists and soy it
just isn't  so easy there now so
when you notice how great the pressure is
and we are now the mother is
exactly the one who just runs out of
patience because they just see what
happens and then you know the
problem is the year 22
realities colliding  who are
actually incompatible politics is
the art of compromise and a
politician stands up and says look,
we did it but that couldn't be done
with the fdp or
whoever the fdp puts
itself up saying we did it
green they just don't play
along but they have to get along with each other
they're elected
we did that by the way and we
elected them and v  request
to do it somehow like this and then there is such a
reality that it is simply 1 or 0
climate change 1 or 0 that is
black or white is in the end it is
just a very simple hard
moral question it is good or bad
that is that is the
decision you have to make are you for good or are
you for evil so hard must tell us and
and that doesn't work compromise a
bit but not so much against something
that no decision that's a
bit allowed but we now have to
additionally ten years millions of
explained to people is dangerous white
problem is that many see it but of
course millions say but that's why they are
not allowed to fly to mallorca
that's why no false we are allowed
to explain that's exactly it's
probably I'm not that
pessimistic about myself I see many
i hear many young people tomorrow how
many of them can see being vegetarian
or consciously eating meat  So
this whole neck steak debate that
asks geometrically on the biscuit that
's really not the point anymore of course
people are allowed to eat their meat but
in the future we will anyway
produce meat differently from how it is artificially
bred and no more animals will have to
die for it that's it then  always
thank god it's all over factory farming
will probably
no longer exist at some point and then it will also work
co2 neutral etc. but
you know that the big topic is
we talk about it and have to
convince people the point is we come
up with a situation more and more often  where it
really feels there is a world against the
in pakistan, for example,
it no longer drops below 40 degrees at night we have now met in india when it
no longer cools below 40 degrees at night
the temperature in parts of the
middle east, for example, has been many in recent
years  traveling in the middle east
really a lot
that's crazy that it will
soon be unw  be unlivable in the summer it will be
uninhabitable there you can no longer
be if at some point you have the
air humidity which then
also moves up then that is
physiologically
life-threatening for us humans then we can
no longer be there but which is
interesting, for example, again if  you
look at israel water water is
also the issue yes in the middle east
but the israelis are so well
positioned with extremely clever
irrigation this drip irrigation
etc but also with water production that they
are now selling water although
there is actually no water at all
i.e. through desalination plants  a statutory
facility that is the other side then
you drive down to the dead sea and it
is this more there is no more
this dead sea is actually
two seas because they now
sometimes run through promontories because
the mirror is simply canceled to such an extent
that that  none no connected
water  che more is my dead sea
then you see the jordan for example
where john the baptist was traveling
biblical big place that is a
trickle that is pulled out so much water
i wouldn’t have had a river anymore you think
that’s a big river that yes or
no  when it's gone it's over and they
're just looking at the colorado
river in the usa that's a
trickle now and that
's what's happening there places where i saw
it many years ago ten
or twelve years ago in ethiopia
at the border up there at the
two av that is at the border to somalia
eritrea ethiopia there is that the the the effect of
the african rift valley yes that
the hottest place on the planet the
sales at that time temperatures of 50 degrees
and and above and if you  then on the
ground there is probably something that should grow you
have 60 degrees how should something
else grow there it's crazy I met people who said nomads there
has e  s it hasn’t rained a drop for three years
i was
there the last camel fell over one
camel
fell over just died of thirst i
drank some water there something out of a
bottle when i never forget that
it’s a dust it’s so fine
because it  it simply hasn’t rained for years
that it gets into every camera, every
crack everywhere and then i
drank water and then i fell or
i i think i just tipped
the last
drops out of this bottle just like
that, all over it  dry dust and then
you have these two three four five six
drops of water on this dust and
immediately a little goat pounced
on the water inside because it immediately
hung up because it was so thirsty it was
crazy is because despite everything
optimistic or are you me  I think
that, as I said before,
we really have to get co2 out of
the air and capture it,
that's the end of it  word if we invent it or
that will already be rolled out swiss
for example they do it in
iceland for example if is also the question
if you if you need energy when you get co2 out of the air
where does this
energy come from you have to and if it again
co2  growth causes nothing
gained it is pointless that is why, for
example, in iceland is the swiss
company that
does that iceland has geothermal energy just as
infinite energy available through these
hot hot springs the heat in the ground
and they pull water out of the co2 there, so to speak
the air and
then press it and that it seems to
work if you could scale something like that
then it will work but
i also remember a
conversation with bild.de many years
ago on lake constance we always met
and we only met for a very short time  talked about
climate change and he
said something very interesting at the time that he
told markus the biggest problem with
climate change  del is
going on
and that's true it's slow and
that's why most people
don't understand what's happening there and of
course it's the job of politics to
really lead that's the classic job
of politics
sorry
is close to my heart i think i
can so medium  So if it's completely
clueless I remain sorry that
others have to try to understand
but then there are days like today in
Hamburg 30 June and
I can't actually enjoy it
because I think it's still normal
that's right now  the fact that it is only a
harbinger that is actually a
problem is that we should
n’t let that happen i think i
think the weather is nicer than
in hamburg there you can
enjoy it i actually think
the team agrees we have to be
careful that the lightness  doesn't go
completely down the drain if we
always charge everything so highly ideological morally
so that she likes it  e more and more
difficult
so that's why now on the beach some
may even like it thank you
made thank you